The people you see on the screen, are
students doing the last design project for this course.
That's what you'll be able to do, as
well. Creating a useful product using the design principles
of affordances. Conceptual models and signifiers. Plus the
design skills that you learned in the earlier projects.
Now, here's a brief overview of the course. In
Lesson 1, we'll ask you to go out and
take some photographs. But we'll also show you
how to take photographs that tell a story. Sometimes
one will be enough, sometimes it might be four
or five photographs. And then we'll learn how to
critique them. Decide whether this is effective. Does it
do a good job? In Lesson 2, time to
construct something. We're going to have you do a surprising
construction. One that, well, guess what? It'll really be
pleasurable and fun. Unexpected. Lesson 3, we're going to put it
all together. That's the capstone course. So in Lesson 3, you
have a project that's going to put together all of the
principles you've learned. And the projects that you've done before. Enjoy.